introduce me to this woman sitting next
to you holding your hand
brother kevin this is francie frane soon
to be francie chapman
and and the last interview we did was
a long time ago not long but a few
months
and you said do you think that losing
your wife is going to help your dog help
other people that have went through this
and i said yes by the way kevin i talked
to a lady before i got here
she had lost her husband the wife just
lost the husband like two months ago
out of nowhere died so
wow i'm thinking i need to meet with her
you know tomorrow before this
right well kevin meet francie
so nice to meet you so nice to meet you
okay so
you talk to this guy he gives you advice
and i didn't know who he was
no no you had no idea no so
when did you meet after that you guys
talk but then what happens
we talk first she goes hi it's doug
there because i left a message on her
husband's phone
how we initially met was you leaving a
message for a box right i left a message
for bob
said this is dog this is dog chapman i
want to talk to so when she called
she's like is doug there and i go yeah
what who's this
you left a message because carlos slept
oh yes ma'am i said i need to talk to
bob
and then she took a deep breath and said
bob is no longer here
well at a meeting with holy ghost people
six months before this lady walked up
and said oh my god
dog the bounty hunter's wife beth just
passed away
and she's like who's dog the bounty
hunter here he is she goes he needs a
haircut
and she goes i'm telling he's been
giving me such a hard time about that
i don't think he needs a haircut i just
didn't know who he was then
so she says francie you're gonna meet
this guy
now she's in arizona i'm in hawaii it
was two days after beth had passed away
that my friend had saw on
youtube that beth had passed away from
throat cancer i didn't know who they
were
and she told me that um she really felt
like we were supposed to meet
and that we were gonna meet each other
and so i
told her you're nuts so when i called
and said
she said doug then when i she said that
was six months later
six months later she passed beth passed
paul passed and as we hung up i go
excuse me man by the way
i'm not doug this is dog dog the bounty
hunter
and all of a sudden like for a minute
and i finally gotta go
hello and she's like hi
and i had no idea hung up come see you
so i
all of that's running through my mind
what happened in arizona and it was six
months later
and i uh was pretty
taken back by all of it as soon as i
hung up the phone with him i
called my girlfriend and i was like okay
are you sitting down right now
because you're not going to believe who
i just talked to
so she was screaming i told you
so i it was
six months after that that
we actually talked again when you asked
him that question
yeah and his other friend saw an
interview with me and you at 4 30 in the
morning
and she goes francie my god go to four
minutes and 45 seconds he says your name
so she goes on there and you and i are
talking and i go i just talked to school
named fran
it's really fancy and blah blah blah
she's like oh my god
so then we made another connection and i
brought
ask her for dinner and it didn't happen
so i kept telling him i'll come and meet
you but this is not a date
yeah is that what you said no i will
meet you but don't get it
don't get it twisted this is not a date
so
we i mean we made this
this friendship started because
we get what the other ones going was
going through
is still going through we're both still
grieving
we're never going to leave bob and beth
behind
forget about them they'll always be a
part of us
we thought we were going to spend our
lives with them
the rest of our lives with them and
that's not what happened and we were
dealt
a really hard hand and
i think both of us had a decision to
make are we going to rise up from the
ashes
of where we are and get back to
life and what beth and bob would have
wanted for
us and then god does this amazing thing
there's no way in a million years we
would have met each other
through any other circumstances i want
to ask you because
when i went to visit dog in colorado he
was hurt
yeah how did you help him
get through this time period
i think the biggest part is that we
understood
the pain that the other one was feeling
and and those tough tough days
and moments we helped each other
stand up and we could cry with each
other
and talk about what we were feeling at
that moment
the thing that we were missing what we
wouldn't have with
them anymore and we were able to walk
alongside
of each other through the pain and the
heartbreak
that we were experiencing and it brought
us together in this
amazing way if you could say something
to bob
about this man that you met what would
you say to him
i know with all my heart that bob would
approve of
who dwayne is as a man
and the first time that i knew that i
loved him he was standing in my garage
he's trying to quit smoking he's doing a
really good job thank you
and it was like 20 degrees outside
and that night when he got home he
called me and he said
when i was in your garage i told bob
that i promised i would always
be so respectful to you and i would
treat you
like a gentleman like a gentleman and i
would always take care of you and i knew
at that moment that he had my heart
and um i know that that's what bob would
want
for the person that i'm going to be with
and he is all of those things and more
that is beautiful and
thank you what would you say to bethany
about francie
if a man like francie
walked up to beth and i love you and
i'll love you forever
and was a good christian talks to god
every day all day she reads the bible
all this that
i would walk away to this day say beth
you go with him
because you're going to go to heaven be
sure you go so i know
she would be so upset if i got some
people been through what i've been
through so if i
she would say okay that's good stay
right there
all right i see that beautiful ring tell
me about the engagement
because you set everything up didn't you
you had a hole
well you know it's not my first rodeo no
david in the bible was married eight
times this is your last time
yeah the uh you buy two my gary boy said
dad
welcome to the girl gets two rings so
after the wedding then
i she has another one so how did you
propose tell me about the i got down on
one knee
and said francie frame will you marry me
and i said can i i'm saying it so i said
listen when i get down
then i want you to get down to on your
knee
and help me back up right
like you i'm getting down so are you
mama and so i got down and she's like
standing there
i was crying and nervous and you did she
didn't even pull me back
up i had to limp up that's not true
you're exaggerating
whatever he did a great job and it was
really romantic
how's your family because you you just
got engaged to dog the bounty hunter
so what was the reaction of your family
so
i didn't tell anyone that we were seeing
each other i wouldn't go anywhere in
public with him
so there's a couple of restaurants in
the town he lives in
that know him really well and so i know
that there's not
pictures and people and all this so i
would only go to those two places and
meet him
because i didn't want anyone to see me
in public or
be splattered all over some tabloid
and i kept easy now they're my friends
honey i kept telling him
like i just don't think i fit in your
world like i'm
from this small town in colorado it's a
cowboy town
a horse town and i just don't think i
fit in your world i don't know how this
is going to work
and the more time i spent with him and
he's amazing the more the longer ranger
i became
[Music]
so when my son i called my
daughter-in-law and i
said i really want you guys to meet
someone
and um she goes okay
this doesn't sound good and i said no
it's really good
i just i'm not gonna tell you anything i
just want you to come meet somebody
that's in my life
and so then she called me and she said
you have to tell me
i can't i can't wait and so i
said to her um so i'm dating dog the
bounty hunter she starts screaming on
the phone you're lying
that's not true so
my son i sent her a picture of the two
of us
and then she showed it to my son and he
said you guys aren't funny
like he thinks it's this photoshopped
you guys aren't funny
so i had them come over to the house and
then he shows up at the door
and i think my son sat there for like
five minutes and he couldn't even say a
word because he was shell-shocked
and now they love him my
grandson calls him grandpa dog already
and so he's eight and uh we went to his
school last week and picked him up from
school and that was
like the coolest thing ever so um
they they love him will you tell me
about
the vines on your hands oh so
um i got mine first oh
sorry i got mine first
and um it's really about
uh redemption and new life
and standing back up in a place
where you were in the hardest place of
your life and you don't know how you're
going to do that
and you do and it's it's about
growth and living again and new life
and so and mine has thorns and hers does
it
mine's a male one but you two really
have put each other back together
you were a little broken yeah when you
put each other back together yeah and
we've built this
we have this amazing friendship also
yeah i like her
i like him i like who he is
i love being with him and hanging out
with him we laugh a lot we talk about
everything and on those days
where um those memories come up or
something triggers a
a prick in your heart we cry together
and we talk about it and we we've walked
through
all of this together and have built this
amazing friendship and found love in the
middle of it
do you realize how lucky you are oh no i
mean seriously i'm i'm being dead
serious with you man i've seen you
i do you realize how lucky you are to
have this woman yes sir and i appreciate
you because i love you for you saying
that
thank you thank you so much i'm just as
lucky and every time i look at her
i s when i put those guys in the back of
the car and i go listen let's start over
okay let's start i didn't get paid extra
for that
let's ask god whatever religion you are
to forgive you for the path you're on
now
and follow me brother i'll show you the
way you just follow after dogs uncle
dog's footsteps
i was there and i went to the lord and
said listen i was doing this for you not
for money
that some people didn't like me because
he threw his pearls before the swine
i'm like i did it for you i need
something you give adam a woman
what the heck god where's mine and
francie so when i look at her yeah i
think that's what you got for
thinking of the bible says the last
shall be first and the first shall be
last
my brothers and sisters are last but
first in line
really a lot of 42 years in february
when i first met him and my girlfriend
gave me that word and then i talked to
him on the phone
and i hadn't told anybody that i talked
to him it was a
like a handful of of women that are
close to me
and the one that saw you ask him
that question she lost her husband five
months after i lost bob and i'd been
walking alongside her
through it and she's the one that called
me at five in the morning and said
you're not going to believe this like
he's on the news talking about you
and i never yes
she said i'm watching bethel music at 2
30 this morning and a dog the bounty
hunter
interview pops on my phone i thought
that was so weird because i don't watch
him
and so i watch it and she goes go to
four minutes and 45 seconds
and watch from there and then you ask
him that question
and even then i really thought okay god
are you going to use me to help him
stand back up
and like i've been crying out to you
ever since the day that i lost bob
telling you
either take me home or use me in a way
that i never dreamed possible that i can
make a difference in this world
in the time that i have left so i
thought that it was about that
not about us finding this amazing
friendship and love that we never
thought that we would find again
after we lost them